die kleine alina aus bremen 2001 sie
missbraucht und ermordet ein
verurteilter kindermörder der hand in
der haft mit dieser schrecklichen tat
geprahlt doch die ermittler können ihm
den mord an adelina bis heute nicht
nachweisen und benötigen deshalb gleich
ihre hinweise
und jetzt kommen wir zu unserem cold
case heute abend zur kleinen adelina aus
bremen 200 meter sind es zwischen der
wohnung ihres opas und ihrem zuhause und
irgendwo auf diesen 200 metern trifft
alle li na auf das böse er wird die
zehnjährige missbrauchen und am morgen
allerdings mörder ist bis heute nicht
gefasst aber es gibt einen verurteilten
kindermörder der im visier der ermittler
ist corinna perry fort und thorsten
start gut berichten
die kleine adelina bismarck
ein fröhliches mädchen
lebenswert hilfsbereit und zuverlässig
eine gute schülerin
adelina wächst im bremer stadtteil
kattenturm mit ihrer
schwester auf am 28 juni 2001 wird das
damals zehnjährigen mädchen mitten am
tag entführt
ihre leiche wochen später in einem nahe
gelegenen waldstück gefunden
[Musik]
pastor rüdiger kurz kennt die familie
die sich völlig zurückgezogen hat
er hat adelina als trauer gottesdienst
gehalten
wenn so etwas passiert dann fragt man ja
irgendwann auch nach dem thema der
gerechtigkeit
[Musik]
wie kann so ein fall und es ist ja bis
heute auch die die tatsache dass der
fall nicht gelöst ist wie kann da jemals
wirklich gerechtigkeit passieren
auch bild reporterin corinna pere ford
sucht seit mehr als zwanzig jahre nach
einer antwort auf die frage wie kann ein
mensch einem kleinen mädchen
welches leid zufügen
und warum konnte adeline us mörder bis
heute nicht gefasst werden
ein zehnjähriges mädchen verschwindet
hier mitten in bremen spurlos
[Musik]
ein zweifacher kindermörder gerät ins
visier der ermittler doch hat er auch
die zehnjährige adelina entführt
missbraucht und getötet
er fragt mit dieser schrecklichen tat
doch die ermittler konnten ihm den
worten nicht nachweisen
trotzdem glaubt das landeskriminalamt
bremen bis heute an die angelobung des
verbrechens
der fall adelina aus dem jahr 2001 ist
tatsächlich ein ganz außergewöhnlicher
gewesen neben dem umstand dass das ein
fall ist der große priorität schon vom
gesetzlichen auftrag hat nimmt emotional
alle kollegen die daran beteiligt sind
und kollegen ganz besonders mit
[Musik]
diese emotionale betroffenheit aus der
auch eine große motivation entsteht hat
sich bis heute gehalten auch ganz
aktuell sind wieder kolleginnen und
kollegen mit diesem fall befassen
[Musik]
im jahr 2001 beschäftigt und bewegt der
fall adeline ab es mag die menschen in
ganz deutschland auch bild reporterin
corinna per sofort und ihre kollegen der
bremer bildredaktion berichten vom
ersten tag an anfangs über ein
vermisstes kind
wieder sucht die polizei ein kleines
mädchen
jetzt jagen sie ihren mörder
hat er sie getötet
der fall an elena war für uns besonders
dramatisch weil er verschwindet mitten
in so einem hochsommertag ein kind und
jeden tag hat man nur erhofft dass
dieses kind wieder gefunden wird die
haupt ermittler hatten auch kinder in
dem alter und ja die hoffnung war so
groß dass man dieses kind findet und
dass man dieses leid erspart was sie
mitgemacht hat
[Musik]
adelina und ihre familie stammen aus
russland
sie leben im stadtteil kattenturm im
südosten von bremen es ist der 28 juni
2001 im elften stock dieses wohnblocks
besucht die kleine adelina an diesem tag
ihren großvater
die zehnjährige will für ihre kranke
mutter lebensmittel abholen graubrot
wurst für sich und ihre schwester eine
tüte chips
[Musik]
in einem kurzen interview erinnert sich
anna lenas großvater christian seidel
die letzten worte sein
vielleicht ist dann einsatz ok ich muss
nicht zu haus zu machen wie man gewalt
durch die ist doch klar
anschließend macht sich adelina auf den
heimweg es ist 17 30 als sie die wohnung
ihres großvaters verlässt die wohnung
ihrer mutter liegt in sichtweite auf der
gegenüberliegen straßenseite doch dort
kommt sie nie an bild reporterin corinna
ab erfurt geht den weg den auch adelina
genommen haben könnte noch einmal ab
es sind nur 200 meter von alinas
großvater bis zu ihrer mutter das ist
der weg den adelina möglicherweise
gegangen ist wo sie ihren peiniger hier
begegnet ist weiß bis heute niemand
als adelina in den nächsten stunden
nicht auftaucht meldet ihre mutter oxana
sie bei der bremer polizei als vermisst
nach anlaufen einlaufen dieser
strafanzeige wurden noch in dieser nacht
fahndungsmaßnahmen durch die in bremen
befinden sich in streifenwagen dann aber
auch sup maßnahmen mit polizeikräften im
wohnumfeld
getätigt und es wurde auch ein tornado
suchflug mit wärmebildkameras
durchgeführt um
zu versuchen hinweise zu erlangen
kurz nach ag linas verschwinden wenn es
sich ihre mutter roksana auf einer
pressekonferenz mit einem bewegenden
appell an den möglichen entführer
[Musik]
ich habe einen teil von mir verloren
meine vierjährige tochter vermisst ihre
große schwester auch ganz wenn sie mich
hier sieht und hört ich bin bei ihren
gedanken und ich hoffe dass sie wieder
bei mir werden
[Musik]
es folgt die bis dahin größte suchaktion
in der geschichte bremens eine
schaufensterpuppe trägt alinas kleidung
vom tattag per fotomontage kommt ihr
gesicht dazu mit diesen plakaten in
deutsch und russisch suchen die beamten
nach adelina schon bald kennt jeder das
vermisste mädchen aus dem bremer
stadtteil kattenturm
[Musik]
wir haben auch neuland damals betreten
weitgehend neuland das war gerade im com
eine internet homepage mit sub material
also mit polizeilichen
veröffentlichungen wurde in die
öffentlichkeitsfahndung 1 spielt sich
hinter mir eins der damaligen
fahndungsplakate es wurde eine belohnung
in höhe von 10.000 die mark damals
ausgelobt dass es später noch mal auf
20.000 d mark erhöht worden die bremer
polizei bildet eine 40-köpfige
sonderkommission
durchleuchtet wie in solchen fällen
üblich das familiäre umfeld schnell
beraten der schwiegervater und adelina
als leiblicher vater ins visier der
ermittler er lebt in sibirien und das
war auch gar nicht einfach den auftritt
spüren der sich vielleicht verschleppt
dass er sie wieder in russland haben
möchte dass die sehnsucht zu groß ist
aber adelina war nicht da und
auch dieser hinweis wurde dann
löste sich auf
es ist der siebte oktober 2001 drei
monate nach elenas verschwinden das
sogenannte pastoren wäldchen ein kleines
waldstück
in der leester marsch südlich von bremen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wenn ich ins sammlerin entdeckt einen
blauen müllsack darin die sterblichen
überreste von adelina kosten
wie sich später herausstellt die
zehnjährige wurde sexuell missbraucht
bevor sie getötet wurde
100 tage lang hatte ein stadtteil eine
stadt ein land gehofft adelina lebend
wiederzufinden
und er steht nun in trauer
[Musik]
würdiger kurz ist pastorin der gemeinde
bremen kattenturm der heute 57-jährige
hat adelina damals zu grabe getragen
adeline us mutter deren großvater die
menschen im stadtteil bei ihrer trauer
begleitet
wie kann man so etwas einem kind antun
das waren so eine eine der fragen die
ich immer wieder gestellt hat
[Musik]
eine zweite sache war für mich dass ich
ein eigenes kind habe eine eigene
tochter die damals und fast genau dem
selben alter war und ich habe auch immer
wieder überlegt was wäre gewesen wie
würdest du reagieren wenn das dein
eigenes konto
die ermittler fragen sich bis heute wer
hat die zehnjährige adelina bismarck im
jahr 2001 missbraucht und getötet
ihre leiche keine zweieinhalb kilometer
von ihrem wohnhaus entfernt in einem
blauen müllsack entsorgt
rund um den fundort der leiche suchen
die ermittler damals nach weiteren
hinweisen und finden in dem er
der staat unter anderem
anzüge eine umstands miederhose und
damen strumpfhose die schlussfolgerung
der ermittler bei dem täter könnte es
sich um eine transvestit ish veranlagten
fetischisten handel ein sexualstraftäter
der bestimmte kleidungsstücke des
anderen geschlechts erregend findet
auffällig der blaue bock den adeline am
tag ihres verschwindens trug fehlte am
leichenfundort
[Musik]
weitere heiß
philipp lahm ist heute bewusst nicht
preis
sie dürfen aber versichert sein dass wir
eine ganze vielzahl von fundsachen von
möglichen spurenträger dort polizeilich
sichergestellt haben und die befinden
sich alle noch zu unserer verfügung für
die weitere aufarbeitung des verfahrens
und möglicherweise wenn sie benötigt
werden auch für eine gerichtsverhandlung
in unserem gewahrsam
die zehnjährige adelina bismarck
verschwindet am 28 juli 2001 spurlos
nach einem besuch bei ihrem großvater im
bremer stadtteil kattenturm nur 200
meter von ihrem zuhause entfernt
drei monate später von einem pilzsammler
in eine kinderleiche eingepackt in einen
blauen müllsack es ist carina
das kleine mädchen wurde sexuell
missbraucht anschließend getötet
die ermittlungen in den folgejahren und
natürlich im schwerpunkt direkt
anschließend an das auffinden des opfers
haben einmal bedingt dass wir uns
auseinander gesetzt haben und mit
ähnlichen straftaten und nach spuren
parallelen gesucht haben und
gleichzeitig haben wir einen
personenkreis von mehreren hundert
sexualstraftäter also personen die in
erscheinung getreten sind mit dem
verdacht einer sexualstraftat auch das
haben wir abgeglichen drei jahre später
im sommer 2004 erschüttern zwei
kindermorde die region in cuxhaven
altenwalde wird die achtjährige levke
entführt und getötet
rund 100 kilometer von bremen entfernt
in neu ebersdorf und 90 km von bremen
entfernt
der gleichaltrige felix beide kinder
verschwinden am hellichten tag werden
sexuell missbraucht und getötet
für die morde an liefke und felix
verantwortlich der 30 jährige marc
hoffmann aus bremerhaven er wird zu
einer lebenslangen freiheitsstrafe mit
anschließender sicherungsverwahrung
verurteilt
als hoffmann gemeinsam mit einem
zellengenossen im gefängnis einen
fernsehbeitrag über die getötete adeline
ab es mag anschaut deutet er an auch für
diese tat verantwortlich zu sein
[Musik]
und tatsächlich die ähnlichkeit von
liefke und adelina ist offensichtlich
beide sind grundschülerinnen beide
tragen langes haar sind schlank und
haben eine brille beide verschwanden
mittags in der nähe ihres zuhauses
die ermittler versuchen war kaufmann mit
einer gezielten polizeitaktischen aktion
zu einem geständnis zu bewegen
sie führen den kindermörder ins pastoren
wäldchen den fundort von kardelens
leiche
[Musik]
wir haben dort eine puppe hingelegt die
die gleichen sachen und natürlich auch
die gleichen haare und so weiter wie
adelina an dem tag das ende des
verschwindens anhatte und normalerweise
wird das aber dieser kindermörder der
hat sie dort nicht gestanden
mehrere psychologen sollen bei dieser
tatortbegehung und der konfrontation mit
der adelina puppe auf jede regung
hoffmanns am fundort geachtet haben
offenbar ohne ein greifbares ergebnis
hoffmann schweigt bis heute
[Musik]
im laufe der jahre haben die ermittler
fast 2000 spuren abgearbeitet sind
1235 hinweisen nachgegangen ohne
erfolg
der fall adelina pacemark wird zum cold
case die familie hat sich komplett
zurückgezogen erklärt pastor kurz
man weiß sehr genau dass eine sache die
nicht gelöst ist für die angehörigen
einfach eine dauerhafte belastung ist
und in so einem fall eine unvorstellbar
hohe belastung
jeder der kinder hat der sich ein ganz
bisschen vorstellt wenn das mit dem
eigenen kind so etwas passiert und man
weiß im endeffekt nicht was wirklich
dahinter steht wäre es gewesen ist ich
glaube da geht ganz ganz viel in einem
selbst drin kaputt
[Musik]
auf der seite des bundeskriminalamtes
steht der von adelina bismarck als
ältester auf einer liste von 50
fahndungen und auch die polizei in
bremen will bis heute wissen wer kann
angaben zum verbleib der gegenstände
machen insbesondere zu dem kurzen blauen
bock dena de mina bismarck am tag ihres
verschwindens getragen hat
[Musik]
wer hat am 28 juni 2001 nach 17 30 rund
um das wohnhaus von adels großvater in
der theodor billroth straße im bremer
stadtteil kattenturm besondere
beobachtungen
und wem ist im sommer 2001 im
sogenannten pastoren wäldchen in der
leester marsch südlich von bremen etwas
ungewöhnliches aufgefallen
denn bis heute mehr als 20 jahre nach
dem mord an der kleinen adelina hoffen
die ermittler noch immer den fall zu
lösen
wir befinden uns bei mehreren personen
die damals beleuchtet wurden in einer
art schwebezustand es konnte keine
schuld nachgewiesen werden aber eben
halt für eine anklage reichte es nicht
ob täter mitwisser oder zeugen melden
sie sich bei der bremer polizei
damit aus dem cold case adelina bismarck
nach mehr als 20 jahren ein aufgeklärter
fall wird
[Musik]
ein fall der einfach nur unglaublich
traurig macht und bis heute kann die
familie nicht abschließen weil sie eben
nicht weiß wer ihre ag nina ermordet hat
die polizei die ermittelt weiter und
benötigt ihre hinweise ob täter
mitwisser oder zeugen melden sie sich
bei der bremer polizei unter 0421 362 3
888 damit aus dem cold case alina
bismarck nach mehr als 20 jahren ein
aufgeklärter fall wird